not only Trump backing down on his
claims about Russia but we have to talk
about that Mexican wall oh how the
tables have so quickly turned before
Donald Trump has even been inaugurated
in terms of what he promised to do and
what he will even try to do never mind
what he will actually do I will build a
wall and Mexico will pay for it too
promises they're number one I will build
the wall and promise number two Mexico
will pay for it he used even his tagline
believe me folks Mexico will pay for it
the wall may never be built but if it is
Donald Trump is now asking Congress to
fund it this means that you trumpets
and non trumpets who pay taxes you are
paying for the wall if it happens
Trump's transition team signaled to
Republican leaders in Congress Trump
wants to pay for the wall through what
we call the appropriations process also
known as your tax money how is Trump
framing it by saying we'll get a refund
from Mexico you know how sometimes you
go to Best Buy and you get a surge
protector for ten bucks but there's a
$10 mail-in rebate and you're gonna get
that money back so really it's gonna be
free Pat that's what's going to happen
with the Mexico wall that will cost
eight to ten billion minimum here is a
tweet from Donald Trump about this issue
the dishonest media does not report that
any money spent on building the great
wall will be paid back by Mexico later a
will report that you're saying it Donald
it's just not going to happen as Mexico
has made clear and there is no legal
basis to force Mexico to give us money
for the wall you can't write this stuff
that you would have to be genuinely
delusional to believe this stuff right
now yeah there were some things from his
campaign that it seemed out obvious at
the time that he would back down from
putting Hillary Clinton in jail that was
never going to be feasible I mean this
was the central hallmark of his campaign
that he would build a wall between the
u.s. and Mexico and then he would turn
around and have the Mexicans pay for it
even Republicans who were asked about
this new scheme aren't saying that
they're going to go with it Steve Steve
Scalise a Republican from Louisiana he's
the number three Republican in house
leadership said we
want President Trump to have all the
tools he needs to build the wall we're
in talks with him on the details we've
still got a few months before there's
another funding bill we want to build a
wall he wants to build a wall noticeably
missing from that statement from Steve
Scalise is we're okay appropriating
money to pay for the wall now there's an
idea floating around which is let's take
all the foreign aid that we give Mexico
and say we'll only give you the money if
you give it back to us as a
reimbursement for Don's wall but the
numbers don't support that case Mexico
gets on under two hundred million
dollars a year from us the wall will
cost at minimum 8 to 10 billion another
idea was double the border crossing visa
fees even if you double them it's still
not going to be enough money to cover
this and then the other idea was just
start seizing the money that immigrants
from Mexico send back to their families
in Mexico that's insanely heavy-handed
for the party of small government I've
said it before I will say it again
have the Trump is realized that they're
being bamboozled and when Trump talks
about the leverage that we may have in
this sort of deal he talks about the 50
billion dollars or so trade deficit with
Mexico yeah but that trade deficit has
to do with businesses in Mexico not
foreign aid or anything else weak we
can't the government doesn't have a
position to you know overrule that no it
has to do with a business environment it
has to do with trade policy it has to do
with Trump you know one of the ways to
address that would be these heavy-handed
forced tariffs that Trump has already
said at least in his negotiation with
carrier that he would back off of
amazing take a break back after this
today's program is made possible in part
by blue apron delivering pre-portioned
ingredients directly to your home for 10
bucks per person per meal but we've got
a great special offer for viewers of the
David Pakman show on the menu this week
spaghetti squash and marinara with
mushrooms and garlic knots spicy shrimp
and Korean rice cakes with cabbage I
made this last week and it was a hit of
course it was just me and my girlfriend
eating it but still it was a hit with
100% of the people in my household I can
tell you that for sure the best thing
about blue apron for me
is the pre-portion ingredients you get
the exact amount of each ingredient down
to the toppings that you need for the
recipe no waste I hate throwing food out
we've talked many times about the crazy
amount of food 25% 33% close to half if
you consider food that is never even
making it into grocery stores and has
just left on on the fields of farms we
waste between 25 and 50 percent of the
food that we grow don't add to that by
throwing food out in your home and with
blue apron that is one of the many great
benefits you can start today with three
free meals and fluo free shipping at
blue apron comm slash Pakman that's PA
que ma n blue apron comm slash PA que ma
n